>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC
>> Joan Weeks: Good
afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
On behalf of all my colleagues, and
in particular Dr. Mary Jane Deeb,
chief of the African and
Middle Eastern division,
I'd like to extend a very
warm welcome to everyone.
I'm Joan Weeks, head of
the Near East section,
the sponsor of today's program.
We are very pleased to present
this program on the poetry
of Jawdat Haydar, a
transnational framework.
However, before we start today's
program and introduce our speaker,
I'd like to give you a brief
overview of our division
and the resources in the
hopes that you'll come back
and use this reading
room for your research.
First of all, this is
a custodial division.
That means that we house and serve
the collections to researchers
from around the world through
all the 78 countries and more
than two dozen languages.
The Africa section is comprised
of all the countries
of sub-Sahara Africa.
The Hebraic section
covers Hebraic worldwide.
And the Near East section covers
all of the Arabic countries,
particularly of North Africa,
Turkey, Turkic central Asia,
all the Arab countries in the
Middle East, Iran, Afghanistan
and the Muslims of China.
Even the peoples of the Caucuses.
So it's a very extensive
collection and we really want
to encourage people to come in for
their research and further programs.
We'd also like to invite you to
try out our Four Corners blog.
We have special little
fliers in your seats
that show those very special
blog posts by our curators.
Very interesting stories and very
special items about our collections.
And if you like us on
Facebook, subscribe,
you'll find out about
future programs.
And also many interesting
facts about our countries.
So also I'd like to remind you
that you're more than welcome
after the presentation
to ask questions.
But since we're videocasting this
presentation, if you ask questions,
you're implicitly giving us
permission to rebroadcast them.
Also after the presentation
I'd like to invite you
to a very special display
of the poet.
This is a very special time
of the year at the library.
We celebrate April as poetry month.
And so this is a very special
opportunity to celebrate that
and see a display of the poet.
As well as some refreshments.
And so we really appreciate
those and invite you to come back
to the conference room after
the presentation for that.
So right now I'd like to invite our
Arab world specialist Nawal Kawar
up to the podium to
introduce our speaker.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Nawal Kawar: Thank you, Joan.
I'd like to welcome everybody today.
I really enjoy having you all.
First I'd like to welcome
our speaker, Dr. Carol Fadda.
And I appreciate her
coming all the way
from New York to be with us today.
Dr. Carol Fadda earned her BA and MA
from the American University
of Beirut.
She graduated from Purdue University
in August 2006 with her PhD
in contemporary American literature.
Her work on US ethnic
literatures focuses
on Arab-American literary
studies, designating the complexity
of Arab-American communal
and individual [inaudible].
She teaches undergraduate
and graduate courses
on Arab-American cultures
and literatures,
US ethnic literary text, war
narratives from the Middle East
and its diaspora, and gender
and sexuality in the Arab world.
She has taught at the University of
Shirja in the United Arab Emirates,
Purdue University in Indiana,
and St. Joseph's University
in Philadelphia.
Her journal articles on
gender, race, ethnicity, war,
trauma and transnational
citizenship in Arab
and Arab-American literary texts
have appeared in the journals
of Studies in Humanities, MELUS --
Carol will spell it out later on --
the Greenwood Encyclopedia for
Multiethnic American Literature,
[inaudible] and College Literature.
Her essays have also appeared in the
edited collection Arabs in America:
Interdisciplinary Essays
on the Arab Diaspora, 2006.
Arab Women's Lives Retold: Exploring
Identity through Writing, 2007.
Teaching World Literature in 2009.
And Arab Voices in Diaspora:
Critical Perspectives
in Arab Literature, 2010.
She's currently working on a book.
No, she's not currently
working on a book.
I am reading the old one.
She just completed her book
entitled, Between the Transnational
and the Ethnic: Arab American
Literary Renegotiations
of Self and Home.
Which looks at the wide
variety of literary texts
by Arab American writers spanning
the second half of the 20th century
to the present to examine
the pivotal role
that the Arab homeland plays
in shaping Arab American.
Please help me welcome
Dr. Carol Fadda.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Carol Fadda: Let
me grab my computer here.
Thank you so much for
that introduction.
And I've been instructed
to speak close to the mic
so that you can all hear me.
And if for some reason I move
away from the mic, just wave
and I'll come close to it.
So thank you so much for all being
here on such a beautiful day.
It means a lot you know when we
leave the sun outside and come
and sit in this beautiful library.
I want to thank the
Library of Congress,
especially the Near East section of
the African and Middle East division
for hosting us in this lovely space.
I also want to thank Mrs. Hasheen
Al-Saddon, Mrs. Dean Al-Saddon
and also Ria Al-Saddon for
inviting me to be part of this event
and to speak about the
wonderful work of Jawdat Haydar.
So my talk today will
be focusing on the works
of the Lebanese poet
Jawdat Haydar who was born
in 1905 and passed away in 2006.
Placing his poetry in a
transnational framework in order
to analyze how such a framework can
be used to link for example the US
and the Arab world in ways that
exceed and trouble neat divisions
of here and there,
the west and the east.
So also this transnational
framework will help us to read
and study writers like Jawdat Haydar
alongside Arab immigrant writers
in the US, most notably the
Bajhad writers whom I will speak
about more in a bit.
But part of my talk also today
will show how the works of writers
like Jawdat Haydar who did not
necessarily reside long-term
in the US, nevertheless include
an important transnational link
between the US and the Arab
world as well as other places.
That helps us in thinking
about literary
and poetic production beyond
the limits of national contexts.
So and then I will move to talk
particularly about some poems
from Haydar's body of works.
I would argue that the poems
of Jawdat Haydar provide us
with an important lens
to consider a vision
that straddles multiple national
locations without necessarily taking
on ethnic or hyphenated identities
such as Arab-American for example.
The transnational aspect of
Haydar's poetry navigates multiple
belongings, literary influences
and humanistic investments in ways
that necessarily complicate again
the neat divisions between here
and there, the Arab
world and the west.
And by doing so reject the
limited and rigid values attached
to these binary divisions.
With you know, what
we're very familiar with,
with the Arab world being
depicted as backward and the west
as civilized and progressive.
So looking at how these poems
trouble and complicate that.
So again Haydar's poetry questions
these binaries by presenting
in his body of work as a
whole a transnational vision
that ultimately exceeds limited and
prepackaged notions of identity,
nation, belonging and citizenship.
So just to speak a bit about
this transnational framework,
because I've taken
it up in my own work,
whereby I discuss the literature
of Arab-American writers,
mainly focusing from
the 1990's onwards
to show how these works
exhibit forms of connection
to the Arab world and to the US
that point to a fluid, multiple
and complex form of
national belonging
that cannot simply be contained
by single citizenships
or national identities.
And we see that in a
variety of ways in the works
of the Arab-American
writers I study,
whether it's Lebanese-American
writers,
Palestinian-American
writers, Iraqi-American,
Egyptian-American, et cetera.
And what about this concept
of the transnational?
Let me just say something
about it quickly.
To think about you know the
transnational and people
who perform this notion of
transnational belonging,
to think about how it mainly focuses
on embodying a simultaneous physical
or metaphorical placement in dual
or even multiple locations that cut
across national boundaries.
Transnational enactments are far
from being uniform or
consistent, however.
They include physical
mobility but also extent
to imaginative attachments.
All promulgated by the
fast development of tools
of communication such as
the internet and others.
So these transnational enactments
vary depending on the conditions
that enable or prohibit
people's access
to multiple national
locations, whether by virtue
of geopolitical conditions,
generational divides,
or economic means.
So what I mean by this is that even
when we talk about the transnational
as bridging two places, we
also have to keep in mind
that not everyone can
travel easily between places
and nations and cross borders.
So it is with these understandings
in mind that I argue for development
of a complex transnational
discourse,
a discourse that overturns fixed
and conventional adherences
to diasporic, national
and ethnic labels
and underscores larger structures
of belonging, citizenship
and national membership
that transform the limits
of the nation state.
At the same time, it places
racial, ethnic, gendered, religious
and sexual identities outside the
rigid constructs of traditional
or normative, cultural
and national frameworks.
So again I want to kind of
see how that is an evidence
in Jawdat Haydar's poetry and how
that poetry negotiates this
multiplicity of belongings.
And just to kind of say
a bit about the context
of an immigrant framework, in
order to place that in conversation
with Jawdat Haydar's own experience,
so this transnational consciousness
is not a new phenomenon.
And other scholars have written
about it in a historical context
in relation to the Arab
diaspora and Arab immigration.
And so we see how transnational
connections between Arab homelands
and the diaspora are very much
in evidence during the first
period of Arab immigration.
And so just to kind of quickly
say that Arab immigration
to the US spans roughly
three periods, three phases.
The first one extends from the
1880's to 1925 or mid-1920's.
Which is 1925 is the year that the
Immigration Quota Act was passed.
And that limited the
number of immigrants
to the US based on
their nationality.
And the second wave of
immigration started with the end
of World War II, '45 to late-'60's.
And the last phase facilitated by
the passing of the 1965 Immigration
and Nationality Act extends from
the 1960's to the current period.
So that's also helpful to know
because the various literary
movements in the US as well
as the movements that straddle the
Arab world roughly follow these
three waves of immigration, early,
middle and contemporary period,
with the Mahja writers coming to
the forefront in the first period.
And so this is -- I just want to
kind of talk about that quickly
because it's important to know
that phase in terms of placing
that first phase in relation to
Jawdat's own experience in the US.
So during this first period we
have the Mahja writers including
of course Khalil Gibran,
Ameen Rihani, Mikha'il Na'ima,
and Elia Abu Madi among
others, who immigrated to the US
and eventually resettled in
their original homelands.
And they wrote in both
English and Arabic.
In 1920 they established in
New York what came to be known
as Rabhi mik Colonia,
or the Pen League,
consisting of both Syrian
and Lebanese writers.
And they maintained a
solid transnational outlook
in their physical and
intellectual negotiations
of Arab and American identities.
So again, to emphasize
this early period,
and in order because
this is the period
when Jawdat Haydar you
know came to the US.
So in order to get an idea of what
kind of literary space was happening
or existed within the US.
So turning to the life and works of
Jawdat Haydar, we see that somebody
like him cannot be easily
placed within a specific
or rigid hyphenated identity,
because he himself was
not an immigrant per se.
But came to the US to study,
after which he returned
to his native Lebanon.
But as I will address here in a
bit, his poems nevertheless point
to a multiple and varied perspective
that cannot so easily be defines
as US-based or solely
Lebanese per se.
For these poems exhibit an
elusiveness and a range of places,
themes, commitments
and relationships.
Writing primarily in English,
Jawdat Haydar published his
first anthology, Voices,
in 1980 which was followed by
Echoes in 1989 and Shadows in 1998.
In 2006 he published his last book,
101 Selected Poems
at the age of 101.
So after graduating from North
Texas State University in 1928
and upon his return to Lebanon,
Haydar kicked off his career
as principle of the Universal
College in Hallab, Lebanon,
after which he assumed
the directorship
of the Nahda National School
in Nables in Palestine.
In 1932 Jawdat Haydar became the
first national staff employee
in the Iraq Petroleum
Company, initially appointed
as assistant employment
officer in Syria.
And then he became industrial
relations advisor in 1956.
After which he subsequently became
general manager of the Mid East Oil
and Trading Company until
his retirement in 1965.
Haydar was also the founder and
president of [inaudible] or Oasis
of Literature in the Baca Valley.
And a member of the Union
of Lebanese Writers.
His poem, The Temple of
Baalbek has been incorporated
into the official curriculum for
the Lebanese national baccalaureate.
While a copy of the poem
currently hangs in the museum
at the temple of Baalbek.
More recently the faculty
of arts and humanities
at the Lebanese University also
passed an official decision
incorporating Haydar's poetry
into its national curriculum
at the university level.
And he's been the recipient
of numerous medals and awards.
And there's a really
wonderful display
of these awards in the next room.
So after the talk we
can take a look at it.
So it is during his time in the
US, after he graduated from UAB
in 1925, he came to the US.
And so after -- it was
during this time here
that Haydar first started
writing poetry.
He graduated again from the
North Texas State University
in '28 with a BS in education.
And so we see him writing
about the US
and this is the poem Dear Old Texas.
And I'm not going to read all of it,
but if we take a look at the end,
it says, "Home again, home again
to Dixie Land; the ship will
and merrily I land; on the shore and
straight I go to the plow; the hat,
the pistol, the horse and the
cow; I love thee old Texas,
I love thy land; I love the plains,
rivers, rocks, hills and sands;
I love they flag, heaven,
nature and sea; God keep you,
God safeguard your liberty."
So in fact this love of
and attachment to the US,
specifically Texas, is also
elucidated in the poem Sweet Home,
which he wrote while he
was working in Nables.
So again here you know we see him
returning to this space of the US
and specifically Texas
as a space of belonging
that he is longing for actually.
And then he says, "Yes, those days
of old were resplendent and fair;
when nigh the sycamores with dear
Jack and Lee; I jovially rallied,
played and learned
to care for the land
of the real, the land of the free.
Oh no more, nevermore, those
homely sunsets; no more, nevermore,
those song sparrows to hear;
for the queen moved to take me
where she sits, on the horizon
and old Texas the dear."
So now this poem and the
preceding one might be used
to simplistically assert a
singular type of belonging
that elevates the US and Texas to a
higher level of national attachment.
However, such a reading falls short
when considering the larger scope
of Haydar's poetic works in which we
find multiple and complex assertions
of love and attachment
towards a sense of place,
nation and one's own
standing within these spaces.
As well exceeding singular
or binaristic spaces
that are pitted against each other.
For reading Haydar's poems through
a transnational lens enables us then
to place poems like Dear Old Texas
and Sweet Home both temporally
and spatially alongside poems
like Lebanon and others like it.
In which the concepts
of freedom, democracy
and national pride are not
restricted to one nation or country,
but one that Haydar locates in
multiple and interconnected spaces
that are connected through
his transnational location
within and across them.
And so we see that similar type of
you know, exploration and veneration
of a place happening
in a poem like Lebanon.
And towards the end he says,
"Oh life, there is nothing more
to enchant me than this vision of
growing ecstasy; I feel dissolved
and carried fancy free where
beauty and dreams meet in policy."
And he says that's the Lebanon.
This is the last stanza, "That's
the Lebanon, the heart of the world,
where the cedars living for
ages unknown and the flag
of liberty always unfurled and
a democracy without a throne."
And so here he's talking
about Lebanon.
In thinking about Haydar
and his work
within a broader transnational
framework, what is noteworthy
about his writing in relation to for
example the Mahja poets who lived
and wrote in the US for
most of their adult life,
is that Haydar's writing
enacts a similar investment
in a transnational viewpoint
as that of the Mahja poets,
but from the location
of the Arab world.
Which again contributes
to a sense or a worldview
that is not restricted to simple
notions of national expression.
And I would argue that this
is the crux of my argument,
that it is primarily a unique
aspect of Jawdat Haydar's work
and in fact distinguishes
him from the Mahja poets
and that he was located in the Arab
world but wrote in English mostly,
a combination that
complicates in a positive way
and captures the interconnected
aspects of what is often presented
and perceived as east
versus west, here and there.
So thus we see here how a
transnational poetic vision does not
necessarily have to emanate from
a US context, but can be based
in an Arab context while
asserting the fluidity of belonging
that literature articulations
bring forth in varied ways.
And that is something that the Mahja
poets collectively struggled with
and worked on throughout
their lives,
because they ultimately occupied
a different positionality
than that of Haydar's.
I want to emphasize though that
such a transnational poetic vision
that I've been discussing is often
juxtaposed with the restrictions
and limitations of physical
boundaries and borders.
And we see that affecting
Jawdat Haydar himself
when for instance we
see him after graduating
from the American University
of Beirut, he went to France.
And he was trying at first
unsuccessfully to get a visa
to study in the US
while he was in France.
So the story goes that he by chance
met the American consult's wife
in a movie theater and she offered
to help him procure
a visa to the US.
And we also see the difficulties of
border crossings and the conundrums
of national identities,
especially for colonized peoples,
even when supposedly returning home.
When Haydar could not procure a
passage to Lebanon from the US
because he would be entering
what would be referred
to as French mandated territory
and that he was still
identified as a Turkish subject.
So I'm giving these examples to help
us think about not only the ease,
but the difficulty of
crossing borders and enacting
that transnational vision
that I'm talking about.
So we see here a link between the
lives and works of Jawdat Haydar
and the Mahja poets, which
is a recurrent thematic focus
on cultural negotiation, and in
between this, specifically in terms
of east and west relations,
cultural difference
and political instability
affecting their home country.
Even though as John Monroe states,
Jawdat Haydar himself did
not experience the feeling
of being pulled in two
different directions,
sometimes toward the east and
sometimes toward the west.
I would point out that Haydar's
poetry nevertheless exhibits
sensitivity, awareness
and investment
in such cultural negotiations.
An awareness that might not emanate
from again an immigrant
experience per se,
but one that is nonetheless
shaped by experiencing the US
and specifically Texas as an Arab.
And then living and travelling
in the Arab world as a Lebanese
but with multiple cultural
registers and experiences.
Moreover, even though as Monroe
writes in his book, Jawdat Haydar:
the Voice from Baalbek, that
and I quote, "Haydar's sense
of alienation was quite different
from the alienation as experienced
by the Mahja writers,"
it is inevitable
that Haydar was quite cognizant
of the negative representations
of Arabs in the US, and the extent
to which these representations
were internalized by many Arabs
and Arab-Americans themselves.
So for here we have a context
of a long history of orientalism
that defines western
attitudes toward the east.
And just to speak briefly about
it, you know, this kind of back
and forth was not only you know,
Arab immigrants coming to the US,
but also there's a back
and forth movement.
Because American culture
in the late 18th
and 19th centuries was characterized
by what [inaudible] describes
in US orientalism as
a race to the orient.
So we have merchants,
travel writers, tourists
and academics among other explorers
and opportunists sweeping the orient
in pursuit of treasures,
whether they be material,
spiritual or intellectual.
And also accounts of near eastern
and Asian lore and magical tales
of adventure and discovery were
in great demand among the
American public at that time.
Such reports contributed
in fostering
and embellishing an alluring
eastern mystique in the western,
specifically American,
consciousness.
A natural consequence of these
exploratory endeavors was the
inevitable inception of a
valuable vein of discourse
between western and eastern culture.
However, such a rapport, instead of
being a mutual and balanced exchange
of cultural views and ideas,
was initially heavily informed
by a western biased outlook
in matters pertaining
to the perception,
translation and espousal
of the collective eastern mind.
And of course some of
these western perceptions
of eastern thought were
initially transmitted by the waves
of Christian missionaries
who flocked to the Near East
in the early 19th century,
specifically to Syria, Lebanon
and Egypt in pursuit of converting
the masses into Christianity
and hence -- you know,
as described by them --
redeeming their own
souls in the process.
The reactions emanating
from such western encounters
with the east greatly
contributed to shaping the manner
in which eastern characteristics
and images were absorbed by
and imprinted on the American mind.
So this intellectual and even
dominance-oriented expansion towards
the east however may be offset
by a counter movement towards
the west led by Arab immigrants
and students seeking their
fortunes in the Arab world.
And so there were serious
implications of this exchange,
right, in terms of these western
missionaries and scholars going to
and describing the
east on western terms.
However the US's early what is
referred to as benevolence control
in the Arab control presented it in
a largely positive light for Arabs,
especially when compared to
the colonial roles of France
and Britain in the region.
Which is why it is not surprising
that Jawdat Haydar's attitude
to the US and his coming to the
US was a largely positive one.
So you know, just to kind of
place it in historical context.
His relatively short stay in the
US might have helped maintain
that positivity which
differs for example
from the increasing disillusionment
faced by many of the Mahja poets
in the US and what they described
as the country's excesses and greed.
However, if we look at the long arc
of Jawdat Haydar's poetic output,
we see him denouncing the causes
and effects of immigration,
which he comes to describe as
detrimental to the Arab psyche,
advocating for the Lebanese
for one to stay at home rather
than pursue the dreams of success in
the west and specifically America.
The urge that characterized
many of the early immigrants,
including the Mahja
writers among them.
And this is one of the things that's
really great about these poems,
is that given that they span
a long historical period,
we can see how they
also can be placed
in conversation with each other.
So for example, in this
poem Lebanese Immigrants --
and I'll read just a
short excerpt from it.
He starts by saying, "Friends,
why spend yourselves on the wings
of time, flying everywhere
and nowhere to land.
Look how the eagles dare the
sky and climb, and wing reach
and back on the cliffs to stand."
And then later on in that same poem
he says, "The alien footing treading
on your threshold to safeguard
the grandeur of your tradition,
by the lion limb you
have had of old,
the mighty shield of
your true position.
Come back, put your food down and
your head up, like proud Sunine
on the breast of our land, with eyes
looking the world from the top up,
our flag down the years of
the brine washing sand."
So keep in mind if you look
at the date on that poem
that this poem is actually written
while the Lebanese Civil War was
still going on and raging.
So to write this poem during
that period, you know to caution
against immigration
is pretty noteworthy.
And not only showing that
Haydar's poetic vision spans a long
historical period and charts
different historical, geographical
and political moments, and the
poet's specific position in relation
to them, but also that his poems
take up thorny and difficult topics
of war trauma and the
devastating effects of conflicts
on individual and collective
psyches.
While the Mahja poets for one,
as well as the more
contemporary Arab American
and other diasporic writers of
the late 20th century onwards
for the most part accessed the
wars, unrest and political conflict,
from the vantage point
of the diaspora,
Haydar lived those experiences
from within the Arab world
and wrote about them in English.
Which provided access
to a wider audience.
For one Haydar wrote
extensively about the Lebanese war
in this poems, warning
the destruction of Beirut
and denouncing the violence
that overtook his country.
Again, writing about it not from
the vantage point of the diaspora
but from within Lebanon itself.
And he says in this poem -- I'm
going to read the last part,
which is cut from here so
you can -- I'll just say it.
"Never mind, history will record
the crime, and timing time,
timely will avenge blood for blood;
just to make the balance sheet
right; and I'll stand there
on the highest mound to spit now on
every year once on the whole world,
to lubricate the tools
of its mechanism.
Perhaps it will wheel right to the
palace of justice so that the people
on earth may enjoy
their safety tomorrow."
And that's written
on August 12th 1982.
However, attesting to their
thematic versatility --
and you know, I really do need
to emphasize that the range
of his poems also shows the thematic
versatility and the multiple themes
that he takes up in these poems.
So again these poems do not focus
singularly on the Lebanese War
or on Lebanon, but explore stated
and unstated far-reaching effects
of such violence on individual
and collective psyches.
We see in Haydar's later
poems for one a turn to nature
that elucidates a continuing
interest in and influenced
by the romantic poets, which he has
also written about in his poems.
On his poetic style, Jason Lewan
who is an assistant professor
of creative writing at AUB,
he writes, "He, Haydar,
boldly fuses the poetic styles
and sentiments of the romantic,
Victorian and modern periods
of Anglophone literature while
exploring issues of common interest
to people living in regions as
far apart as Texas and Iraq."
And so we see also that versatility
of the poems coming through in
that broad thematic reach.
You know, and expressing
his influence and admiration
of the romantic poets, we have
a poem here titled In Memory
of Wordsworth and His Sonnet
Upon Westminster Bridge.
And he says, "Wordsworth, I stand
where you once stood before,
on this bridge of antiquity and
fame; where emperor, tourist
and troubadour have come to
London in honor of your name."
And he says, "Wordsworth, your
words worth being a tableau,
pranked by the lifelike hue of
your sonnet; with the stately views
of the world that show old London
wearing a gray sky bonnet."
And he says, "Although you fell
silent long ago, you are enlivened
by your posse; to remain
time-honored in your chateau,
bearing the regal crown of posity."
And so at the height of the Lebanese
Civil War, Haydar chose to retire
in his hometown Baalbek where
he spent the rest of his years.
It is also in Baalbek that Haydar
established what I referred to early
as [inaudible] or the Oasis of
Literature, a society of poets
who strove to revive Lebanese poetry
and enhance collaboration among
the poets of the Baca valley.
And under his presidency,
it's noteworthy that Oasis
of Literature restored the statue
of the renowned poet Khalil Tran
to the entrance of the
historic city in recognition
of Tran's prominence
as a native scholar.
And Haydar dedicated the rest of
his years to farming and poetry,
a wonderful combination
in my opinion.
Insisting he is a farmer at heart,
Haydar over 90 years old relates,
he says, "I still farm my land to
get the fresh smell of the earth."
And in an interview shortly
before his death, Haydar states,
"My secret for long life
is always being thankful.
Life is a gift.
Be happy when you can."
So the simplicity of these words
belie a rich and complex vision
that understands and well
articulates the conundrums, ironies,
joys and pain of a life
richly lived and experienced.
And I'm going to end
here with this poem
which I think really
captures the vision
that runs throughout these poems
and span a long historical period,
but captures that essence
of these poems.
And it's titled Going Back.
"We start going back
on the road we take,
walking ahead to the outset behind;
that's how of birth we are stepping
to make, a ring back on
the track into the blind.
That's a round trip we are
destined to run, climbing the hill
and railing down the slack; and
railing we signal the day is done,
and what is done, a
journey ahead and back.
Sure, we come going with the ticks
of time, a distance measured by fate
and we fall; never to stand
again, never to climb,
heaven and back and
gone beyond recall.
That's how travelers ahead walking
back, leaving impressions only
of name; and memory of the walk
on the track and the track trails
and smoke behind the flame."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Now for questioning.
>> Nawal Kawar: Thank you, Carol.
That was really wonderful.
Anybody has a question, please?
Yes? Mary Jane, carry on.
>> Thank you very much.
That was wonderful.
And I wanted to ask you,
did Haydar have a group?
You know, sometimes poems belong to
a group of other poets and writers
that share the idea
with their community,
whether in Texas or Lebanon.
>> Dr. Carol Fadda: From my
readings I saw that you know,
he had a good community
in the US and Texas.
And you know, that partly explains
his favorable experience there.
And you have a really
good experience.
But from what I read, you know,
he was the only Arab in there.
So that's also interesting, to see
how he was engaged in the community
as someone who's Arab and coming
into that community
from the Arab world.
But in terms of Lebanon, you know,
the Oasis of Literature
group is really interesting.
Because that shows that
he had the big investment
in not only producing
poems individually,
but also collaborating.
And having this sort of communal
sense of artistic production
that was invested in showcasing the
works of other poets and writers
like Matran, and placing him
very centrally in the square.
So there definitely was an
investment in collectively producing
and insisting on artistic
production.
Yeah.
>> Nawal Kawar: There
is one over there.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Dr. Carol Fadda: I
didn't catch the last part.
I'm sorry.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, he went to EB.
I mean, I can't speak to
why he decided to do that,
but I can also speak of
what does it mean to write
in English as an Arab poet.
And so I would say that also shows
a kind of approach to writing
that is not limited to you know
as an Arab one only
writes in English, right?
Or you know, so that also shows
a kind of educational background,
also an exposure where English you
know becomes a way of communicating
and writing that is not
only restricted to writers
who are in the US, right?
Or in the west.
So I think that's the point
that I'm really interested in,
to kind of think about if you want
to call it Anglophone literature
as literature that doesn't only
emanate from the west, right?
Or is only owned by
a western context.
But also how writers positioned
in the Arab world also engage
linguistically with English in order
to produce their own visions
and their own relations
to the language, right?
And also to kind of
show that versatility
of linguistic and artistic
production.
That becomes part of you know
Anglophone Arab cultures.
Okay.
[ Inaudible ]
So the first poem on Texas,
I think that was published
in a college newspaper.
So we can count that as you know
the first publication and reception
of that poem, which was
received very favorably.
And you know, I also want
to note that the mere fact
that were having this event today
in the Library of Congress attests
to the reception of these poems
and these works that you know,
extend beyond a certain timeframe.
Right, so then how we think of
the reception of these works
and the ongoing reception
of these works in a kind
of longer time frame
is also important.
>> Nawal Kawar: I think
we have a couple
of questions, and then -- okay.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Dr. Carol Fadda: Probably.
I mean, this is all conjecture,
but also the kind of thing
about the Mahja poets like
Gibran and Ameen Rihani,
their experiences I think in Boston
and New York are significant,
you know.
So location I think plays a
big part in how do you interact
with your location or what kind of
community do you find yourself in.
You know, because most of the
Mahja poets lived and wrote
in Arab immigrant communities.
So I think that also shapes
that vision significantly.
So my response would be absolutely,
location, who you're connected with,
who you interact with,
these communities
around you are ultimately going to
shape your vision of that place.
[ Inaudible ]
Primarily it's that form.
Right, yeah.
And there are other I think --
this one, so there's a variety.
So we see here in this poem
there is a variety there.
And also you know, looking at the
scope of the poems is important
because then we see how
there's a change over the range
and the scope of these poems, right?
So that's versatility, absolutely.
[ Inaudible ]
So the experimental part, like how
are we defining the experimental,
right?
Because if I'm thinking
of experimental,
I might go through the
extreme and kind of think
about extremely experimental poems.
So even if he is not experimental
in that sense, I would see a kind
of shift in form and trying
different forms throughout
the poems.
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
So I think he has an
autobiography you know.
He wrote an autobiography
so that's kind
of another genre that he worked on.
But his primary focus was on poetry.
[ Inaudible ]
I hear that he did, and Mrs.
Al-Saddon was just telling me
that they're honoring him.
Maybe if you can speak more to that,
because you were just
visiting the university.
[ Inaudible ]
>> I'm very pleased to see
all of our friends coming
to share with us this event.
I would say that he was always
in contact with everyone he knew.
He was such a friendly person
and wanted always go keep
in good relation with
everyone and everywhere.
And the reason why he did not --
may I answer this question,
if you don't mind?
The reason why he wrote
directly in English,
I suppose he was the only one
who wrote directly in English
since he was 16 years old.
Because he was deprived from
learning Arabic in Lebanon,
we were under Turkish rule.
And his family was
against the Turkish rule
and they were exiled to Turkey.
And here he was, only
eight years old.
His mother, he stayed with his
mother when he was eight years.
His mother passed away.
She was sick from typhoid.
And here he was all on his own.
He went and asked the Turkish
responsible man at the gate
of the train, "I want to go to my
parents, to my father and brothers."
And they said, "Go away,
you little boy, from here."
He said, "No, I want to go.
Otherwise I'll try
to write a letter."
You know, his father was like
a judge and so the man said,
"Okay, I will let you go."
Then he went to Turkey.
He was deprived of Arabic,
was learning Turkish.
He came back.
The British troops were looking
over that the Turkish
would leave Baalbek.
He was there and he was
listening to their language.
He was fascinated by the
English language and he said,
"I must go to the new world
and I must learn this language.
It's so beautiful."
And so he had a private tutor.
This is after all the
family came back in 1917.
And he learned English,
went to the American school
which is not the American school.
It was the International
College, IC.
And so he was very good in English.
He wanted to go to the States,
and this was how he was
deprived from the Arabic.
And when he came to Texas, his
teacher was so in love with Burns
and she used to all
the time read for him.
So my father stood up and
said, "Sweet, don't be proud
of thy fairly good eyes," so and so.
And he said, "Oh, a poet is born.
A poet is born."
Then the Dallas newspaper published
his first -- he was 16 years old.
And then when he came
back to Lebanon,
of course he was studying
Arabic as well and everything,
but he felt that English
was the tool
that he could express
his feelings and himself.
That's why.
And when he published his
first book, he sent his poems
to Vintage Press here in New York
and they immediately you
know, they were published.
And since then he kept on writing.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Nawal Kawar: Mrs.
Al-Saddon, she is the daughter
of Mr. Haydar, if nobody knows here.
Nobody hears me?
Mrs. Al-Saddon is the daughter
of Mr. Haydar the poet.
Okay, now we come to an end.
And please, everybody is
invited to the reception.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.